both Korea was at the heart of the
latest UN and Security Council meeting
Washington's top diplomat Mike Pompeo
praised progress made in relations
between the two countries just a year
since President Trump vowed to totally
destroy the reclusive State past
diplomatic attempts to halt North
Korea's nuclear and ballistic missile
development were unsuccessful but now
we're at the dawn of a new day so twelve
months ago Washington and Pyongyang seem
to be standing on the brink of war so
will this new day mentioned by secretary
Pompeo last Ilia Petrenko reports from
new york it's only been a year and then
boom Donald Trump's second UN General
Assembly just listened to it I would
like to thank chairman Kim for his
courage and for the steps he has taken a
lot of very positive things are
happening with Chairman Kim he likes me
I like him we get along but most
importantly I believe that Chairman Kim
jong-un wants peace and prosperity for
North Korea twelve months ago same
building same halls same mr. Trump no
one has shown more contempt for other
nations and for the well-being of their
own people than the depraved regime in
North Korea no North Korea hasn't
undergone any regime change surgery
Chairman Kim is still in his chair but
miraculously little rocket man is now an
awesome guy rocket man shooting Rockets
all over the place and with me he's not
getting away with it he will truly
regret it fire and fury the likes of
which nobody's seen before totally
destroy North Korean rocket man Mad Men
is on a suicide mission for himself is
that a dare it's a statement well today
kim jeong-hoon is the president's most
admired pen pal i'm sure you've heard
about the beautiful letter so i've
received two letters from chairman kim
much personal correspondence magnificent
very strong letter form incredible
letters a letter that
when I showed one of the letters just
one to Prime Minister Robby he said this
is actually a groundbreaking letter like
any other president Donald Trump would
love to be remembered as a true global
peacemaker it took him a year and a half
from his inauguration to zero in on his
desired legacy a true breakthrough in
the Korean crisis Barack Obama was
having a harder time cementing his place
in history books but then the Iran
nuclear deal came to the rescue and
mission find your perfect legacy was
complete after nearly two years of
intensive negotiations backed by strong
sanctions the countries represented in
this room achieved what decades of
animosity and rhetoric did not and
thanks to this deal we have seen real
progress shortly after mr. Obama was
gone
the deal was left in tatters no matter
how monumental it had been in the first
place I've ever seen the disastrous deal
one of the dumbest deals one of the
worst deals ever was the Iran deal
I'm all for agreements but that was a
bad one Donald Trump waved goodbye to
the agreements he quit
unilaterally without paying attention to
pretty much what the rest of the world
has to say about it
today's action sends a critical message
the United States no longer makes empty
threats when I make promises I keep them
Donald Trump may indeed keep all his
promises as president but it does happen
that rivals sometimes take over at the
White House after term one what if in a
couple of years someone else will be
representing the u.s. behind these UN
General Assembly walls in New York a
million Petrenko
we spoke to Eric sir Watkyn co-founder
of the lawyers for demilitarization and
peace in Korea he believes that despite
Washington's efforts to strengthen
relations prospect of any peace treaty
with the north is no closer it is hard
to judge whether their statements match
reality however just meeting by
dialoguing and talking is progress and I
think it needs to be acknowledged and
praised that they are doing that however
have we moved any closer toward a the
idea of a peace treaty have we moved
any closer toward finding a way to avoid
these nuclear buildup on the peninsula
I'm not sure through the efforts of
Washington that we have I think we have
through the efforts of president moon
and South Korea and what they're doing
but I don't think at this point in time
we can say progress has been made
because they should be entering a peace
treaty ending the Korean War as a
prerequisite to talks
you